next we have vaccines as several have
mentioned it's extremely important to
have safe and effective vaccines
available for everyone in this country
as well as globally in that regard we
put together myself and some of my
colleagues and published in science
magazine a few weeks ago what we call a
strategic approach to coronavirus 19
vaccine research and development it's
not a comprehensive plan about every
aspect of vaccine but it is a strong
plan regarding the research and
development pathway and what we have
done in this is that we have what's
called a harmonized effect because we
know there are many vaccines that are in
trial now at various stages and what we
did and the federal government thanks
the generosity of the Congress has put a
considerable amount of money in order to
harmonize the trials of multiple
candidates from different companies so
that we have common endpoints common
dative and safety monitoring board and
common immunological parameters that are
being funded and are being pursued in
addition there are a number of different
platforms that are being pursued so that
we don't have all our eggs in one basket
as you know one of those is right now
getting ready as we approach next month
of going into phase 2b trials and others
will be staggered along the way in the
middle of the summer end of the summer
early on there is no guarantee and
anyone who's been involved in
vaccinology will tell you that we will
have a safe and effective vaccine but we
are cautiously optimistic looking at
animal data and the early preliminary
data that we will at least know the
extent of efficacy some time in the
winter and early part of next year again
working with the companies in the
investment made by this Congress
hopefully there will be doses available
by the beginning of next year